it was the gay pride parade today in New
York which capped a month attached a
great month of significant advances for
marriage equality in America the White
House is granting new benefits to
same-sex couples including those who
live in states where gay marriage is
against the law to date 19 states in the
District of Columbia have legalized
marriage equality and the momentum
continues that's right we are nearly
halfway to full nationwide marriage
equality which means which means which
means it's about to become a question of
which state is going to be last who
could it possibly be Mississippi we
don't know we don't know Mississippi it
could be anyone Mississippi yeah oh I
know it's a little premature but I do
think this might be one of those moments
where we're allowed to feel great about
this country marriage equality is
sweeping the nation and America did it
strike up the band three on the rock
George
this play
hold on because unfortunately this month
has also brought less good news from
other countries there's great
controversy over the new UN General
Assembly president Uganda's Sam Kutesa
has been elected to the largely
ceremonial role but thousands have
signed a petition against the
appointment because of Uganda's harsh
laws on homosexuality yeah calling
Uganda's laws harsh doesn't really do
them justice that's like calling Stalin
a bit of a grump or or the Triangle
Shirtwaist Factory fire a whoopsie do or
the Titanic a disappointing vacation
because let's let's take a moment to
remind ourselves about what Uganda's
laws actually contain on Monday the
President of Uganda signed a sweeping
anti-gay bill into law it makes it
illegal simply to be gay in the country
and imposes harsh prison sentences for
offenders so the moral arc of the
universe is long and it bends away from
Uganda and and the law isn't just
putting gays at risk of imprisonment
since it passed in Ugandan legislature
the number of recorded acts of
persecution has increased between 750
and 1900 percent from previous years
it's gotten to the point where people
from the dark ages could build a time
machine travel to 2014 Uganda step
outside and go a it didn't work ok
nice try get back in now
now you might wonder how can the UN
allow a representative of the Ugandan
government which has also been accused
of corruption and the brutal suppression
of dissent to be in charge of their
General Assembly Sam Kutesa is chosen
without a vote the selection is done on
geographical rotation and African
countries had already agreed he'd be
their candidate oh that's fine then so
it's just their turn essentially the UN
apparently works according to the same
principle as family movie night where
even if your little sister picks My
Little Pony Friendship is Magic Princess
Twilight Sparkle for the third time you
have to watch it because it's half King
turn
the fact that in the 21st century 81
countries have laws outlawing
homosexuality is incredibly depressing
although in a way it shows how lucky we
are to live here because remember when
it comes to advances in marriage
equality America did it am i right
cheerleaders
in our face
okay okay this feels so good
we're just out of interest where did you
gain to get the idea to come up with
such hateful laws Uganda has had laws
against homosexuality for virtually all
the past century they were introduced in
the old British colonial days
whoopsie-daisy I've got to be honest
being British is sometimes a little like
being an alcoholic when someone says you
did something awful you find yourself
going honestly I don't even remember
doing that but yeah probably probably
I'm a dick I'm a dick what do you want
me to say
okay so fundamentally it's the British
people's fault but you know I live in
America now so I've still got a pretty
warm feeling inside me unless someone is
about to take that away from me
the irony gay rights activists say is
that it was a small group of American
evangelicals who came to Uganda speaking
out against homosexuality which was
already illegal that really took the
persecution of the LGBT community to a
new level
wait so what you're essentially saying
is America did this no no no get back to
that cake get back to that cake your
finger get out of here all of you get
out of here and think about what you've
done shame on you shame on you shame on
you
shame on you okay okay so it turns out
American anti-gay activists were in
Uganda in the run-up to the passage of
the law and let's meet just one of them
Scott lively now if that name rings a
bell you may know him as one of those
far-right Christians who go on TV and
say things like this
I think mr. Obama may well be a
homosexual himself hey hey hey hey
that's clearly wrong it's not mr. Obama
it's President Obama President Obama is
a homosexual get it right have some
respect
Chuck if if you live in Massachusetts
you may also know Scott lively as that
crazy guy currently running for governor
and he was attempting to take back the
symbol of the rainbow from the gays by
promoting this song by evil
oh I feel like if Kermit ever heard that
song he would immediately insist on one
fewer songs about rainbows look Scott
lively is clearly an idiot
and luckily over here we just get to
laugh at him you are never going to stop
aids until you stop treating homosexual
sodomy as a civil right and start
treating it as a form of conduct to
avoid the guys material is killing out
there hey what's up with how HIV is only
transmittable between homosexuals not is
this all huh huh this guy knows what I'm
talking about
unfortunately though in Uganda it is a
very different story in America there's
a nobody but in Africa this extremist
guy becomes the spokesperson and is able
to address the entire permit for five
hours I don't know what's more shocking
there but he addressed the Parliament at
all or that he did it for five hours
because listen if your hard-on for
homophobia lasts five hours you need to
seek medical attention and he didn't
just stop there Scott lively spoke on
Ugandan TV and gave seminars attended by
Ugandan government officials and here is
where Scott lively is about to get
considerably less funny increasingly
lesbians are being molested by other
women
becoming more and more common in the
United States dare you say that
homosexuality and pedophilia are equated
well they already claim they have
fertile sense of mercy the Rwandan stuff
probably involve these vents these from
the Nazis the Nazis it's like he just
eats the most offensive package of
magnetic poetry and then vomited it all
over his audience and then later that
year Uganda's anti-homosexuality bill
was introduced and for the record
lively says he doesn't approve of it and
disclaims any influence over it I do not
support and never did support the harsh
penalties in terms of long prison
sentences I don't believe in that I
never have no of course not
he was simply saying look guys gay
people are dangerous insidious Nazis do
with that information what you will live
layouts lively ask why back off now
Scott's on it if God hates gays as much
as you think he does he's gonna be
pretty pissed at you for not seeing this
thing through and and it's not just
Scott lively what one of Uganda's most
prominent anti-gay preachers is a pastor
named Martin semper let's listen in on
one of his lovely sermons do you know
what they are greeting them through
I did research and I gathered
information together I'm gonna side for
an anti-gay pasta that man clearly had
very quick access to a lot of fetish
porn high very Swift just oh there we go
Martin semper is not American he has in
the past however received funding from
the Canyon Ridge Christian Church in Las
Vegas and the US government which
allocated his organization $40,000 for
abstinence education which he presumably
responsibly spent on gay porn to show
during sermons but but if you want a
single sound byte that sums up the
depressing scale of the American
cultural influence on Ugandan homophobia
it is this in the beginning it was it
was Adam and Eve not Adam and Steve
yeah that's not a Ugandan saying let me
give you three names that are not
especially common in Africa Adam Eve and
Steve so clearly us groups recognized
the market for homophobia stateside was
dwindling and so tried to sell it
somewhere else
meaning that Africa isn't just where we
send our losing team Superbowl shirts
it's also where we now send our losing
political philosophies and although the
u.s. is now issuing sanctions in
reaction to these laws this is clearly a
problem that Uganda is going to have to
solve itself and here we may have one
small glimmer of hope because in
researching this story we found a clip
of an interview on a Ugandan morning
show with a transgender human rights
activist named Pepe Julian onziema Pepe
Julian onziema thank you for coming in
thank you for good morning morning - why
are you gay whoa okay so we're just
jumping straight into it then
no warm-up questionnaire straight into
it and that set the tone for that
activists hour-long marathon of
restraint
don't you think gays homosexuals
lesbians transgenders should instead be
reoriented other than receiving all this
kind of recognition because society
seems to deem them as unnatural as
people who are maybe lost someone you're
seated with me right now no one not sure
is that well it's not sure but I'm just
baffled perfect yeah but that's the
point
if you baffled by something you don't
automatically throw it in jail
otherwise American prisons would be full
of Keurig coffee machines is it water
first then the cup do you take the lid
off somebody put this witchcraft behind
bars it's wrong it's morally wrong to
credit Pepe onziema somehow kept his
cool the whole time when you recruit
young boys and girls into into this gay
activism there is no such thing as
recruitment of young people or adults or
anything like that
what is recruitment first of all what
when you asked me about recruitment what
do you mean by recruitment I mean trying
to put them into your system teaching
them what to do how to go about it we do
not do that how does a human being
maintain that level of composure and and
say we do not do that rather than what
the is wrong with you
got it got even worse it got even worse
we're joined by none other than Martin
semper who turned up with a bag full of
vegetables and a lot of questions they
begin to use gadgets like bananas they
use colors they use bananas they use
cucumbers and other metallized ones and
they put the music themselves these
other instruments you use our house of
vegetables uh-huh and he can be severe
like blips Pepe
azeema is the Gandhi of Uganda he is you
Gandhi and I am truly honored to say
that he is actually joining us here this
evening
please welcome
food please
okay yes thank you so so much for being
here I guess my first question has to be
why are you gay oh look so I just
thought that's how all interviews got
started the key question is do you think
this law would have happened if it were
not for us interference the answer is no
it wouldn't have happened if it wasn't
for US influence why I say that is for
very many years we've had a penal Court
and we've done research to find out how
many people have been actually convicted
under the penal code that we have and
there's probably just one case row in
and the person did not serve the
sentence so no but it's not about it's
not about whether the laws are enacted
is it it's about the incitement of the
hatred around exact in in many ways that
can do more physical damage than the
threat of jail terms absolutely of
course with the Penal Code many of us
have suffered under the pinning you know
just the the way it is presented to the
public many of us have suffered from
evictions beatings on the street
arbitrary arrests and so on however that
increased it changed with your influence
or your from always on the double down
you know I I sow that seed as a British
person and now as someone who lives in
America I fertilized the out of
that seat
so you're welcome and sorry on both
counts sorry doesn't cut I love the fact
that we've just seen incredible
restraint during that interview and it's
with movie-going yeah you need to say
soul so so are you safe in
Uganda I'm guessing the answer to that
is not really is that true
not really I'm not exactly safe but to a
certain extent um I'm safe because I I
stand my ground that I'm not going to
change and a fear I'm not going to run
away from the country and the fact that
you guys know about me is a form of
protection for me I I look over my
shoulder every day but there's not a
place I would rather be then be there
and and make sure that the safety I need
actually happens in the country yeah
that's just I cannot tell you how much I
can't tell you how much I thank you for
being here
and how much I admire you for going back
to Uganda gee changings
go for it you Michael do you mind
sticking around and we'll talk more on
the web is that okay sure that'd be
great um if you want to watch an
extended interview of this online please
go down here my huge thanks to Pepe
Julian onziema have a great week we're
off next week we're rocking through its
have a great week good night